by most accounts benedict cumberbatch is
a pretty perfect doctor strange but if
you didn't work as magic the role could
have been taken by a number of other
actors in fact because Cumberbatch
declined his first shot to star in
Doctor Strange due to scheduling
conflicts director scott derrickson
actually met with a number of other
potential masters of the mystic arts
eventually derrickson persuaded Marvel
to build a production to accommodate a
star and the rest is sorceress supreme
history but who were the other actors
who were almost cast in dr. strange
Joaquin Phoenix as far back as 2014
Marvel pursued Hollywood weirdo Joaquin
Phoenix for the part of Doctor Strange
contract negotiations were reportedly
close to agreement but Phoenix said to
have balked at how much time and
creative energy starring in the movie
would consume not to mention the
appearances and other MCU releases that
he'd be obligated to make over the next
few years he ultimately decided he
preferred indie efforts - superhero
blockbusters as vanity fair-- once
pointed out when Phoenix was rumored for
the role of Lex Luthor do you really
expect a guy who seems actively
miserable anytime he has to leave his
house to take on a movie that requires a
visit to comic-con Ryan Gosling
according to the Guardian after Joaquin
Phoenix turned down Doctor Strange Ryan
Gosling took some meetings with Marvel
Studios at the same time he was also
being considered for a role in Suicide
Squad maybe to play a joker who didn't
send dead rats to his castmates and in a
2014 interview that year Gosling hinted
he'd also loved to play the flash for DC
unfortunately for fans of costumed hey
girl names he ultimately didn't land any
of these parts but there are still
plenty of potential roles to go around
Goss lactis anyone Jared Leto director
scott derrickson told empire that when
it looked like Cumberbatch was a no-go
he met with quote a lot of good actors
including Jared Leto hot off of his Best
Supporting Actor win for Dallas buyers
club as we all know Leto would
eventually make his mark in the comic
movie world in Suicide Squad for a full
seven minutes of screen time before
later asking for the release of unseen
x-rated footage that he apparently shot
ultimately this dude would have brought
a level of strange that the doctor
definitely didn't need Ethan Hawke while
doing promotion for his oscar-nominated
turn in boyhood Ethan Hawke mentioned on
a podcast that he came quote as close as
anybody could to plain Stephen strange
Hawke suspected Lee didn't land the part
because he doesn't have a huge fanbase
like
de Cumberbatch nor is he a major
box-office draw a saying if people are
gonna put up with somebody like me they
want to make sure you're gonna put asses
in seats and there's a lot of actors
that are gonna put more asses and seats
than me he's not wrong
Ethan Hawke seems like a guy who wasn't
supposed to be a movie star but he
slipped through the cracks and everyone
was just like okay you and McGregor no
stranger to the weird ways of the
universe there was apparently mutual
interest between Marvel and Ewan
McGregor for Doctor Strange in 2015 a
reporter from MTV asked McGregor about
his involvement in the movie I was
intrigued by and I liked the idea of
creating a being with you know got a
superhero character yeah why wouldn't
you despite his serious nerd credibility
McGregor believes his lack of comic
knowledge bumped him out of the running
for the role but said it was still fun
to be a part of the mix for a while but
really you can't have Star Wars and
Marvel that would just be greedy Patrick
Dempsey a movie star in the 80s Patrick
Dempsey enjoyed a massive comeback when
he took on a starring role on ABC's
popular soap Grey's Anatomy in 2005 in
2011 he admitted he was looking to get
back into movies specifically with a
movie adaptation of Doctor Strange
Dempsey publicly discussed his
attraction of the character with the Los
Angeles Times saying I've been lobbying
for that it would be fantastic it'd be a
great TV show especially for HBO or
something like that
Marvel obviously envisioned the doctor
on a bigger screen and Dempsey wasn't
part of the picture Nicolas Cage
director writer Roman Coppola is part of
the unstoppable Coppola filmmaking
dynasty years ago before the marvel
cinematic universe was a thing Coppola
set out to make his own version of
Doctor Strange at the time the comic was
still just a cult favorite but after a
chance meeting with Stanley and seeing
how terrible the Fantastic Four was
Coppola was inspired Coppola says he
spent a while planning it and even had
an actor in mind for the role of Doctor
Strange his cousin be actually strange
Nicolas Cage I'm like a prickly pear
though after seeing how cage handled
Marvel's Ghost Rider twice it's probably
best he didn't get the role now in his
50s it might be too late for comic nerd
Cage to grab a hold of another superhero
part
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]